hey guys but is monday the 29th of june
today my name is jess mcdonald and
you're watching games what news Batman
Arkham Knight for PC may be all kinds of
broken but the game has sold more in its
first week in the UK than the witcher 3
wild posted the numbers have come in
through UK sales monitor charts track
who also published the full top 10 list
of best-selling games from the week
ending jun 27 batman pushed lego
jurassic world into the second spot
which was then followed by the Elder
Scrolls online Yoshi's woolly world and
then the witcher 3 wild hunt batman
arkham knight is mel v fastest selling
game of this year so far in the UK it
was interesting to see Sony snag
themselves this year's timed exclusive
call of duty DLC so that tends to go to
Xbox platforms now though PlayStation
have come out to say how it all fell
into place PlayStation exec Adam boys
said they had already built up a good
relationship with Activision through
their work together on destiny and when
acting invited Sony over to see black
ops 3 they quote fell in love instantly
romantica that is he adds as soon as I
started playing it I said this feels
incredible you can wall ride it's just
so smooth it's almost like poetic
needless to say boys felt the bluffs
would definitely be worth the
presumptuously heavy exclusivity
investment and like any good happy
fairytale endings sponsored by Sony
klopse 3 DLC will land on PlayStation
first as will the game's multiplayer
beta finally Star Wars 1313 may not be
completely dead after all as we've now
heard that the new star wars game coming
from visceral games it's dead to bear
similarities to the council title during
a metric on panel nathan drake voice
actor nolan north spoke about veteran
uncharted writer Amy Hennig who's
heading up the new star wars game he
described the new project as in the
style of uncharted and when asked
whether the game was in fact 1330
he said quote it's different but along
the same lines Amy Hennig left naughty
dog for visceral in March of last year
and her departure apparently set
uncharted floors development back by
eight months so far we know very little
about her new Star Wars project except
for the rumor that it's supposed to be
an open-world game let me know down in
the comments what kind of game you want
this new star was titled to be and why
the answer is nice of the old republic 3
you can add the game spot we've got news
on no deaths on map in star wars
battlefront and the potential mafia 3
game that is everything that I wanted to
tell you about today be sure to let me
know what you cared about and are catchy
same time tomorrow